donc ce que nous faisons dans l'apprentissage automatique, nous avons
tendance à nous entraîner à donner à un ordinateur
des données d'entrée, puis à partir de ces données d'entrée, l'
ordinateur doit donner les résultats prédits
[Musique]
mon père est pasteur et ma mère enseignante
donc il n'y a personne  dans ma famille qui était
scientifique,
donc je suis le seul scientifique de la famille,
mais il se trouve que j'étais bon en
mathématiques, alors mes parents et mes professeurs
m'ont encouragé à faire de la science et à ce
moment-là, ils m'ont encouragé à faire de
l'ingénierie, donc mon objectif était d'être  un
ingénieur, mais plus tard, j'ai réalisé
que le monde passe à
l'économie numérique où tout tourne autour de la
science et de la technologie, c'est pourquoi je suis
passé à l'informatique
[Musique]
mes recherches se sont concentrées sur le
problème du décrochage scolaire dans les
écoles secondaires en tanzanie  en utilisant un
modèle d'apprentissage automatique,
j'ai donc développé dans cette recherche une
application Web appelée bakishule,
qui
signifie en swahili rester à l'école afin d'aider
les acteurs de l'éducation tels que les parents, les
enseignants, etc. à prédire et à
identifier facilement les élèves à risque.  d'
abandon pour une intervention précoce, l'
objectif était d'observer quelles caractéristiques montrent une
forte contribution à la prédiction de l'abandon
et nous observons qu'il y
a trois
six caractéristiques
qui montrent une forte contribution à la
prédiction de l'abandon, nous avons donc trouvé ces
caractéristiques en tant que sexe de l'
élève âge de l'élève
les repas  par jour,
une autre caractéristique est si
les parents vérifient le livre de leur enfant
et si les parents discutent des progrès avec un
enseignant, l'application donnera simplement
les résultats prévus si, sur la base de ces
informations, l'élève va abandonner
ou non et ce qui peut être fait dans l'ordre  pour
sauver la situation,
j'ai donc décidé de travailler dans ce domaine
de l'apprentissage automatique, en particulier dans
l'éducation, car
en tanzanie, l'un des défis auxquels sont
confrontés
de nombreux étudiants est le
décrochage
scolaire.  le décrochage sont des filles par rapport aux
garçons qui est de 15 pour cent,
ce qui m'a poussé à trouver une
solution technologique que je peux utiliser pour
aider à résoudre ce problème de
décrochage scolaire dans mon pays
[Musique]
donc mon objectif est
avant tout d'améliorer
ils développent l'application qui est
bakischule car, comme je l'ai dit, c'est un
prototype qui est actuellement utilisé par
plusieurs écoles en tanzanie, donc je
me concentre actuellement sur la réception des
commentaires des utilisateurs afin de l'améliorer,
mais à partir de là, mon objectif à long terme
est de  devenir expert en apprentissage automatique
[Musique]
il est important d'inclure une femme dans
ce domaine scientifique car comme nous
savons tous que nos femmes
sont celles qui
comprennent bien les défis de la communauté,
ce sont elles qui sont confrontées à ces
défis, donc si nous allons être  capable d'avoir un impact sur
les femmes ou les femmes
ayant des connaissances sur la science et
la technologie, il leur sera plus facile de
proposer des solutions innovantes que
vous